[Música]
es una institución que domina el frente
de mar de una escuela distinta a las
demás desde 1822 el centro de
instrucción naval forma a los futuros
aprendices de la marina francesa y hoy
es el primer día de clases
240 jóvenes con edades entre los 16 y
los 18 años han ingresado a la escuela
de aprendices de marinero Liz está
acompañada por sus padres Cuál es su
impresión Desde que llegaste veo a mucha
gente diferente un poco de todo está
bien me tranquilizo un poco no solo hay
deportistas de alto rendimiento cómo
está esta mañana es muy impresionante
mucho orgullo
se da cuenta
[Música]
por su parte Dylan llega de córcega con
un sueño
quisiera ser maniobrero en la Marina por
ejemplo los que maniobran las fragatas
los que maniobran grandes embarcaciones
tales como el Charles de gold
y dirán durante 10 meses aquí en brest
entre clases teóricas y aprendizajes
sobre la vida militar cohesión
disciplina y sentido del compromiso
todos esperan merecer el pompón de la
marina nacional pero la vida de marinero
no es para todo el mundo Entonces para
probarla la primera salida al mar es un
momento emocionante
[Música]
empieza la izada de la gran vela
no apretes tanto el espigón porque no se
sabe si un zodiac llega muy rápido
debemos contar con tiempo para maniobrar
timonial es un puesto de responsabilidad
[Risas]
para Dylan y los demás es la primera vez
aprenden los rudimentos de la navegación
todos juntos
tengo la impresión de que aquí es como
si tuviésemos una segunda familia
durante esos 10 meses de formación Los
aspirantes Marineros son puesto a prueba
en especial durante las temidas salidas
al terreno
se empieza con tres horas de caminata
hoy hace 14 grados en brest mucho menos
en el agua pero no importa Hay que
seguir
en qué está probandolos en este momento
resistencia mental el frío el físico Es
simplemente y veo si el jefe logra
motivar a su tropa es todo cómo les ve
van bien pero no hay que decírselo
en el siguiente ejercicio Liz encabeza
su grupo
Qué hace nos puedes explicar le cuesta
respirar no se siente bien es una
simulación no no se siente para nada
bien
vivirán así durante tres días
esforzándose con frío y en el barro 4
marineros abandonaron en cuanto a los
otros su coraje será recompensado tienen
el honor de desfilar en uniforme frente
a 2500 invitados entre ellos sus padres
Ahora son militares así se escolaridad
aquí no había terminado
[Aplausos]
bueno
en los padres de Liz que se reencuentran
con su hija transformada hay mucha
emoción
no estaba estresada pero cuando los vi
te vi estaba sentado en el piso no sé me
estresé un poco unas cuantas semanas y
estos jóvenes aspirantes saldrán de la
escuela de grumetes con un contrato de
cuatro años bajo el brazo de la marina
[Música]
finalmente podrán responder al llamado
de la lejanía
[Música]